- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our daily homeroom live stream.
For those of y'all who are new,
this is something that we started doing,
it feels like a lifetime ago now,
almost two and a half months ago
when we started seeing school closures,
and we realized that, you know,
it's our duty as a not-for-profit
to step up even more and figure out
how we can not only keep people learning,
but how can we stay connected
in this time of social distancing?
So this is just a place to
have interesting conversations
about education,
about the crises in the world,
and anything else.
And we have a very, very
exciting guest today.
But before we get to our guest,
I'll make my standard announcement,
reminding everyone that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist due to
philanthropic donations.
We were running at a deficit even
before the covid crisis.
And you could imagine with our usage
being two to three X of normal,
and we're trying to accelerate
a whole series of programs to,
keep all of y'all learning,
to support teachers and parents.
And, to support everyone
as we go to this very,
unusual back to school
that we're likely to face.
The only reason why
we're able to do that is,
with support from folks like yourself,
I do want to make a special shout out
to several corporations
that have stepped up.
Bank of America, Google.org, AT&T, fastly,
and Novartis.
All stepped up in the last few weeks.
And this is above and beyond the many
other philanthropists, corporate partners,
foundations that have
supported Khan Academy
through the years that
have put us in a position
to be able to support folks
through a crisis like this.
So thank you to all of them,
but we are still running at a deficit
and there's still a lot that we could do.
And so if you're in a position to do so,
please think about donating.
So with that said,
I'm excited to introduce our guest,
Stu Schmill, who's the Dean of admissions
and student financial services at MIT.
Stu, welcome.
- Thank you, Sal.
Nice to see you.
- Yeah, you know, when we
had you on the guest list,
I was, "What are we gonna talk about?
There's nothing interesting
(laughs)
going on in college admissions
or testing or colleges.
It's just all same, same,
same as always, right?
- Yeah, It's been very, boring
and even, nine to five come home
and actually it's not even
come home anymore (laughs)
- Right, stay home, you
don't have to go, yeah.
It sounds like your attic
room and all seriousness,
obviously, a lot has obviously,
if the sarcasm wasn't
super obvious to anyone,
a lot has obviously been
going on in the world.
I don't know, maybe tell
me from your vantage point,
you know, how has it evolved?
How has your thinking evolved?
What are you seeing from students?
What are their concerns
and, just how do you see
this coming back to school changing
or evolving for a place like MIT?
- Yeah, so I think, the pandemic
while it had been building
for some time over the
beginning part of this year,
I think really, took hold in our minds
in terms of changes that we were going
to need to make over the course
of this spring relatively quickly.
Really get to the end of February,
beginning of March,
and we made some very,
very quick decisions
on what our education was
gonna look like this spring.
And, universities are not always
or haven't always been known
for very quick decision making.
And I was actually very impressed with,
the speed at which we
were able to carry out,
some of the changes that we did.
But also I'm very impressed with,
I know certainly the
people on my campus at MIT,
and I think this is true universally,
is how much we kept the
student at the center
of all of the decisions
that were being made
and tried to make decisions that were
in the best interest of the students.
And, so certainly the decision
to send our students home,
or at least those that
were able to go home,
those who would be safer
from a health point of view,
sending them home very quickly was really
in their best interest.
Standing up, continuing
our education along
in online version.
Very quickly, also trying to ensure
that students had the ability to continue
to make progress towards their degree.
But also there were students
that had very particular circumstances.
So right now there are still
a few hundred students,
undergraduate students who
are living on the MIT campus
because it's a better
environment for them,
than anywhere else that
they might have been able to go to.
And, really, a lot of
decisions that have been made,
were really made with the students
at the center of this.
And I know going forward
because the last few months
we've been planning on
what's going to happen,
as we get near the fall.
And maybe you
or others,
might have questions about that,
as we go along here.
We're also thinking about
what is gonna be best
for our students and our entire community.
Both from a health point of view
and then educationally.
- And what do you see the scenarios?
I know, I mean I'm eager to talk
about how even admissions
has had to evolve
or might have to evolve going forward,
but just your vantage point
in the university itself,
what are the continuity
plans you're hearing
about for this coming back to school?
- Well, we certainly know
that, with whatever happens
and whatever decisions
that are made by colleges
and universities around
what their educations
are going to look like,
it's going to look very different
than it did last fall.
The virus is still going to be with us
and, it's still very contagious
and, you have to be very careful
about, very dense environments.
And universities are
very dense environments.
And, I think, we,
along with many other really all colleges
and universities, acknowledge
and recognize that, online,
or rather in-person education
is extremely valuable.
And we want to see
students come to campus.
We just have to be able to do that
in a responsible way.
And what that will ultimately look like,
it's not yet clear.
It's not clear that
we'll be able to have all
of our students back on campus
or some of our students on campus
and where that line is drawn.
So I think that, regardless
of ultimately what happens,
it will be different
because even if students are on campus,
there will be different expectations
for what we'll be able to do
in terms of, living in the dorms,
will have to be a little
bit less dense perhaps
than we have been in the past.
In the classroom, we'll
have to be less dense.
They'll be, guidance around,
or guidelines around social distancing
and wearing face coverings.
Will there be parties and sporting events
and all the rest of that?
We're not gonna be able
to have the same kind
of large event programming,
that colleges are,
well in some cases famous for, certainly.
But it's one of the things that students
really love about college.
So those things are gonna
change a little bit in the fall.
- And what are you hearing from the class
that you just admitted?
The people who would be freshman?
I'm hearing in the general press,
a lot of students thinking about,
"Well, you know, freshman
year maybe I take a year off
or take a gap year".
How accommodating are you,
all of that type of thing?
And how are y'all advising students
who are thinking that through?
- Yeah, so students,
right now we're getting
a lot of questions.
Students wanna know what's gonna happen.
I think most everybody is,
really hoping that they're gonna be able
to come to campus, in the fall.
We're hoping the same thing.
So we're getting a lot
of questions about that.
And we have had students ask us,
or say that,
"Well, look, if I can't
come to campus in the fall,
then I may take a gap year
or I may defer my enrollment".
Thing about that is,
I think students are saying that
without really even knowing,
well, what are their
other options going to be?
So take a gap year to do what?
So that's not clear.
And also, I think students,
particularly new students are thinking,
well either on campus and
if it's not on campus,
they're thinking that
the online experience
that we may be able to offer in the fall
is going to be like what
their online experience
has been in high school.
And I don't think that's true.
In fact, I know that our faculty
and many of our other
instructional professionals
are working very hard to ensure that,
any of the online tools that we have,
for teaching students are gonna be,
really very high quality
and very different than
what students have seen
and experienced this spring.
And, I think in any scenario,
even when scenario where
students are on campus,
there's going to be some online learning,
that will be happening,
particularly again because,
we have to limit the size
of classes, et cetera.
So I think the quality of
that online instruction
is going to improve.
And so students are,
I don't think they have enough
information yet to know,
whether they really do want
to defer their enrollment or not.
For our part at MIT,
we're going to be very open
and essentially let
students make the decision
as to what they think
will be best for them
once they have all the information
as to what our fall program
is going to be like.
But I don't know how
universal that will be.
I think, there are a
lot of considerations,
that colleges and universities will have
around how many students
that they can allow
and afford to let defer for a year.
MIT happens to be in a
relatively privileged position,
there that, you know,
we can withstand that
from a financial point of view.
- Yeah, no, it's, it's fascinating.
I mean, well we could talk more,
especially if people ask questions
and I'm just reminding everyone,
"If you have questions
and a lot of questions
have already started
to come in on a Facebook and YouTube,
please ask them".
But I think that's a
whole other dimension of,
it sounds like the places
like MIT are going to be,
they're going to be able
to weather the financial storm of this.
But there's a lot of colleges
and universities that were already
kind of on the fence pre-COVID
and this might put them over.
That's a whole other interesting topic.
One question, just because
there's been so much
in the news lately.
I'm sure you are aware, you know,
the University of California system,
really kind of stimulated by covid,
they're like, "Look for
the next couple of years,
SAT and ACT will be optional".
And then they've essentially,
it's not testing optional.
They've, essentially said
two years, three years out,
they're not going to
consider something like
the SAT places like University of Chicago.
We had Jim Nondorf on this show,
I guess that's what we can call it a show.
They're testing optional.
They still have 90% of
their students take the SAT.
Though I think those are the admitted.
How are you thinking about it?
And you know, there are several questions
from Facebook, you know,
(mumbles) "What's the process of judging
an applicant in context?"
So I think that's, you
know, people hear that.
So what's your view on
these standardized tests
and how do you put them in context?
- Yeah, by the way, big fan of Jim Nondorf
and I think what he's done
at the University of Chicago
has been great in terms of,
the way they've approached their testing
because that works for them.
And I think generally the
conversation around testing,
nobody loves testing.
Very few people.
- I love testing, no, I'm kidding (laughs)
- Yeah, (laughs) well,
there are people who do,
I know there are people.
- Actually I do.
- And in fact, you know,
I know when I was in high school,
I wouldn't necessarily say the SAT
was the thing that I loved to take,
but I, you know, went through the,
all the math competitions
and loved all of that stuff.
So, there are students out there who do.
But by and large, people
don't love testing.
And I think what people really,
acknowledges that a test that,
is so high stakes and therefore stressful
and pressure filled,
that determines so much for a student,
that's not good.
And I think we would all agree that,
you know, sitting for one test
shouldn't determine
a student's pathway going forward.
And also people look at the test
and they see that there
are disparate outcomes.
So, low income students,
students of color,
tend to have lower scores on average.
And, so, you know, there's a sense that
there's some unfairness in that.
So my take on this with
MIT though is that,
the tests, the SAT, the ACT really are one
and really the only consistent
measure of some academic,
output that students can offer.
We have students applying to us
from all over the world.
But even in the United States,
there's such a diversity
of, K through 12 systems.
So the high schools in the U.S.
and we're not familiar with all of them.
And, so those standardized tests
are the only real consistent
academic measure that we have.
And we also find at least the research,
is that the tests are the best predictor
of success in our curriculum.
And MIT, right from day one,
is a pretty challenging place
and we wanna make sure that
any student that we admit
is going to be academically ready
and prepared to do that work
regardless of where they come from.
And the tests give us that confidence
to be able to admit students knowing that
they're gonna be successful.
And the tests give us that confidence
in ways that grades alone do not.
And so, for us, the tests play a role.
They are not the only
thing that we consider.
We also are fully aware,
as I mentioned earlier,
that there are, you know, different groups
that will perform differently
based on resources.
And in fact, you know, family income
is maybe the best predictor
of a student's SAT score.
All that said, we're aware of that
and we're aware of that
in the admissions process.
And so you asked a question
or one of our listeners
asked a question about,
what does it mean to, do
college admissions in context?
And what that means is
really understanding the environment,
the opportunities
and the resources that students have had,
and making an evaluation of their talent
and their potential based on
where they come from
and how they've performed
in their context.
You know, one way to think about this is,
you know, imagine two runners racing
and people think that,
"Okay, that's fair".
You line up two people
and you let them run
and whoever gets to the finish line first,
is a faster runner.
But you also have to
consider the fact that,
the two runners may be running
under different conditions.
One may be running into a headwind
while the other has a
really strong tailwind.
And if you really wanna judge the talent
and the potential of those runners,
you have to understand the environment,
the headwinds, the
tailwinds that they may have
in order to make those fair assessments.
So that's what it means
to do admissions in
context is understanding,
the environment
or the headwinds that
students have to face.
- It makes a ton of sense.
And just more tactically short term
because some of the testing
administration dates
have to be pushed back.
Some of the tests got canceled there.
"How are you all thinking?"
This is a question,
Anaf Swat from YouTube.
"What about SAT and ACT for
this coming admission cycle?
How are you all thinking about that?"
- Well, we know that it's possible
that students may not be able to,
have access to tests.
That's possible
and if that's true, we'll adjust our,
admissions process.
Admissions process takes in
quite a number of inputs.
So the test is just one of many,
many inputs that we have.
And, we like to have it
because as I mentioned earlier,
it's helpful for us,
but if we don't have it,
we can still make decisions using
the best information that we have
from the rest of the application.
And, you know, we haven't made
or set or changed our policies
for next year as a number of schools have,
quite a number of schools have said
that they are from next year,
going to be test optional
in anticipation of the fact that
many students won't
have access to the tests
and that may come to pass.
But we're waiting just to see
how things develop in the fall
in the hopes that there will be
some ability for students
to be able to take those tests.
- It makes sense.
And you know, one question,
this is, from YouTube Lauren Crowe,
"Does MIT measure the
passion a student has
in the area they are applying for?"
And I'll just add to that,
you know, there's kind
of these two schools
of thought and admissions.
One is, kind of what you hear,
word of mouth and a lot of,
especially, I would say
competitive high schools
where there seems to be
institutional knowledge,
but they're, you know,
there's a lot of kids
joining tons of clubs,
taking a ton of AP courses.
You know, they might be taking
the SAT or the ACT three, four,
you know, I've heard horror stories,
even more times than that.
you know, and there's this kind
of the stereotypical application
and these kids are kind of
in this pressure cooker environment,
they're kind of check boxing.
That's one school of thought.
But then whenever you talk
to an admissions officer,
there's like, "No, no, no, no,
that's missing the point.
We care about,
you know, your whole being.
We wanna see people who
have a passion in one
or a few areas who have this potential".
So you know, and then I think the people
that first school thought say,
"Oh, well they just say that,
you know, that's kind of
the correct thing to say,
but they really want us gunners".
So, clarify, what's the truth?
- Yeah, so the truth really is
the latter that we really, we...
I'm gonna tell you what
all admissions officers
have been telling you for years and--
- Tell us the truth.
- That is the truth
- No (laughing)
- And the reason why it gets confused...
Well, here's the reason
why it gets confused,
is because, students,
parents make judgements
on very few data points
and in fact data points
that they don't even,
know fully.
They see who gets admitted to our schools
and they make assumptions about
why they may have been
admitted to our schools.
It's never the volume
or the quantity,
of what a student does.
It's never that.
It's always, you know,
who they are as a person, their talent,
really their match with our mission.
You know, for MIT, of course,
we're a school that is centered
on science and technology.
So we like to see that interest.
But we're also a place that's trying
to make the world a better place.
In fact, right in our mission statement
to apply science, technology
and other areas of scholarship,
to best serve the nation in the world,
in the 21st century.
And we are looking for students
who we think are gonna resonate
with that mission.
And if all you are is cranking away,
loading up on activities
and advanced classes
and all the rest of it,
it's very hard in fact.
I think students do themselves
a disservice when they do that
because they don't leave themselves time
to cultivate their interests
and to think about how
they can make an impact
on their communities.
We actually pay attention to that.
You know, how much are students helping
the people around them?
And I think if students are just flat out
and on overload,
they really do themselves a disservice
because they can't put the time
and the mental energy into the things
that really are interesting to them
and develop those talents more fully.
- And how do you discern that?
I mean, to the question from Lauren,
you know, how can you separate
or you know, folks who are maybe
even very sophisticated at applying,
you know, maybe,
there's obviously cases of consultants,
some of which obviously
famously had been illegal,
where, you know, these
perfect applications
versus kids who are truly authentic
about those passions,
and they would have had those passions
even if they weren't trying to get
into a selective university?
- Right, so again, I mentioned earlier,
we get inputs from a range of places.
So on the academic side,
the end of the test scores, the grades.
And there are other ways that students
can demonstrate academic
talent and ability.
We ask students to write essays,
to tell those about themselves
and actually I think while, yes,
there are consultants out there
and students can basically
tell us anything they want to,
we generally trust that students are,
speaking from the heart
when they write those essays.
But we also get letters
of recommendation from,
teachers and counselors in schools.
And those have to align.
And teachers and counselors,
often do a pretty good job at describing
who the students are,
and we make sure there's
some alignment there.
We also offer an interview,
although that's, not every student
has access to the interview,
but many, many do.
And the interview can shed more light,
in ways that are harder to gain.
And, we think that,
we are able to discern
when students are being authentic.
You know, it's so interesting to me that,
after we admit students in a given cycle
and I have the opportunity
to meet with them
when they first come on campus,
so many of them come up to me
and they ask me if they
were admitted by mistake
or they feel like, how is
it that they got admitted?
And, you know, to me that
says a couple of things.
Number one, I mean, I
love the MIT students
and there's a real humbleness,
to the group that, you know,
they don't have this overinflated view
of who they are.
But I think also they recognize that,
they're just regular students.
They're not perfect.
They see their own flaws.
And we don't admit perfect people.
They don't exist out there.
Everyone has flaws and that's fine.
And we're not looking for
that perfect applicant,
that perfect student
because they don't exist out there.
And, you know,
I think that if students
could relax a little bit more
and just focus on doing the things
that are most interesting to them
with as much energy
and enthusiasm as they can,
and not to forget that
they are family members
and community members
and they need to pay attention
to being good contributing members,
to their family and their communities,
in pursuit of something else
they can't give that piece of it up.
Because we're looking for all of that.
And I think if students
could just relax a little bit
and not try to make themselves
into the perfect applicant,
but just to be the best person they can be
and let the applications flow from that,
I think students would have a much
better experience in high school
and ultimately the world
would be a better place.
- You know, and for anyone
who doesn't believe,
Stu, you know,
I'll even use my own personal example,
as kind of a case in point,
where you know, many people know that
I was an undergrad at MIT
and you know,
I went to a school
that had never sent anyone to MIT.
I was somewhat naive about the process,
but I did just kind of very authentically
put my best foot forward.
It looks like I'm
clipping up a little bit.
My internet might be
acting a little bit shady.
My apologies, but that, you know,
I remember after I had applied,
I had met some kids who went
to some of the fancy schools
at a math competition
and they almost laughed at me
when they found out that
I was applying to MIT
cause my school was just
kind of a completely
off the radar, type of place.
And I was actually frankly
very intimidated by them
because when they told me how many
who had applied from
their very fancy school in the past
and maybe hadn't got in,
I was like, "Oh!" (laughs)
I guess I was naive about this process.
But, only later when I did get in
and I kind of reflected about the process
is exactly what Stu was describing.
A lot of, you know, a lot
of those other applicants
were kind of engineered applicants.
And I think, whoever
your predecessors were,
Stu, you know, kind of spotted that,
while they were looking for, you know,
I don't wanna make it
sound like they were,
you know, they did a great
decision admitting me.
I wouldn't even ask y'all
whatever the mistake,
I don't want It (laughing)
But I do see that for real,
that people's perceptions before a college
and then what you see
there, what admissions...
The admissions officers
are telling the reality.
Now, a related question to that, you know,
obviously I had a ...
If someone asks me what
was my experience at MIT?
"Look, I had a wonderful
experience at MIT".
I met my wife there, my
many, my best friends,
some of my best memories.
I still have very positive dreams.
Still, I have times that I'm with my,
you know, sometimes I
forgot to drop a class
and that kind of as a stressful dream.
But I had very positive experience there,
so I couldn't endorse it more highly.
But what do you say to folks, you know,
there's also this sense of like,
name brandism,
"Oh, I've got to go to an MIT,
I've gotta go to a Harvard,
I've gotta go to a Stanford".
Otherwise, you know,
It's the end of the world,
what do you tell that to families
or students who are feeling
that type of anxiety?
- Yeah, again, this is where I feel like,
students would do well
to just think about,
not think of themselves
as college applicants first,
but just to think of
themselves as students
and community members first
and then let the college
admissions process,
fall where it may,
because the reality is,
that, you know, if MIT is a great place,
it's not a great place because you know,
from up on high it's been
deemed that, you know,
MIT is this magical place.
It's only a great place
because the people that are there,
and that the students and the faculty
and the staff that are there,
they make it so,
and so if you're a great student,
you can go anywhere
and have a great experience
and make that place just
as magical and great.
It's really true that, you know,
college is what you make it.
And any college in the U.S.
has more opportunity than any one student
can possibly take advantage of.
And, so students can thrive
wherever they go to school
they find a place that they feel like
really fits the style
and the environment
that they wanna learn.
And any student who takes advantage
at any college is gonna be successful
and you don't need to go to an MIT,
or you know, another deemed brand college.
You just have to cultivate yourself
and someone who's gonna
engage wherever you go.
And that's how you
build a successful life.
- That completely resonates.
A lot of what we've talked about
at this live stream before
is kind of what you put out,
the energy you put out is kind of
what you experience.
And I even gave the example,
I think I've given this on
this live stream before,
when I was in business school,
you know, I went with some stereotypes
of business school,
but then when I got there, you know,
I was kind of open minded about things.
I was very vulnerable, open to folks
and I was like, "Oh,
they're just like that,
they're very open
and vulnerable to me
and they care more about friendships
than you know,
in some ways being competitive".
But then I remember
meeting someone who's like,
"You know, can you believe this place?
How competitive everyone is?
I can't trust anyone here" (laughs)
I was just like, "Are you
on in a different universe?
We're sharing the same air".
But I think, you know, I didn't tell him,
but I was like, "Yeah, I
think you're projecting that".
So (laughs) completely I agree.
You can go anywhere
and have an amazing experience
and you can go anywhere
and have a horrible one.
And it's not always your fault.
Obviously, like I'm not gonna say
like everything that happens to you is,
like what you're projecting,
but a lot of that,
whatever the context is,
can often be shaped
by what you're projecting into it.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- So, Stu, any final,
my internet connection
looks like...
My apologies.
It looks like it's falling apart
and I also have a toothache,
I feel like blaming my tooth on the...
(laughs)
Somehow (mumbles) to make
my whole life pretty...
I shouldn't project onto my tooth.
I should have an open mind rather.
(laughs)
Teaching me something.
But Stu, any final thoughts?
You know, let me just ask,
I'll finish with a big question.
What do you think are really gonna be
the lasting implications on admissions,
on how people view college
and how colleges might change
because of all of this?
- Well, I think we're learning a lot.
We're forced to learn a lot
cause we're doing things
in new mode right now.
And I think anytime you're
forced to make changes,
you learn a lot.
And I think ultimately
when we get back to
whatever that new normal is,
I hope it's not exactly
the way it was in the past.
I hope there are things
that we can take with us,
that go forward.
You know, think about,
certainly online learning is one,
a way that I think we're gonna
learn a lot about it
and perhaps take a hybrid learning
into the future as well.
I mean, Khan Academy, a great example of
an exceptional online learning experience
and, so it is possible to do that.
And I think if we can take that forward
into the universities,
we can understand what matters most,
and optimize what matters most.
And I guess that's
really my final thought,
is, you know, in the pandemic,
colleges and universities and students,
we're all thinking about
how to take care of ourselves
and the people around us
as the absolute top priority.
And I hope that when we do get back
to the other side of this pandemic,
that those values remain,
that we think about,
how can we take care of ourselves
and the people around us
as a top priority
and not get caught up?
We call about getting caught up
in engineering as the,
engineering oneself as
the perfect applicant
and all these other things
that I've just sort of
noise in the system.
And I hope we can all remember really,
what matters most
and take that with us,
when we get to the other
side of this pandemic.
- Now, thanks for that.
That's super helpful and Stu thanks for,
thank you for being part of this.
And I'm sure that there's
a lot of tough issues that y'all
are working through,
but it sounds like you'll have
a good handle on it.
So thanks for joining.
- Great.
Thanks Sal, great to see you
and appreciate everyone
who's watching as well.
Good luck to everyone, be well.
- So thanks everyone
for joining this live stream.
My apologies.
My internet is breaking up
and if I haven't been
at the top of my game,
I'm having a horrible toothache right now.
And so I might have to do some covid safe,
emergency dental, type of thing.
So wish me luck (laughing)
But you know,
I thought it was a
fascinating conversation.
I think, you know, the biggest takeaway
I think from Stu is,
and maybe the covid crisis is,
there's a lot of things that we take
very, very seriously in our life
and it creates kind of
this artificial stress
in our minds that only humans,
you know, other mammals don't think about,
like, "Oh, if I have to go to this college
and I need this score and all that".
And to some degree, you know,
we have a lot of good things as humans,
like, you know, air conditioners
and you know, sometimes computers
and things like that.
But like, we oftentimes
create our own stresses
in our brain, and you know,
the real takeaway is,
if you take that away
and you just be your authentic self
and you just always put one foot
in front of the other
and just try to make do of what you have,
I've quoted frozen to in the past,
to do the next right thing,
then not only will you
probably be enjoying life more,
but probably other people
will want you to be
part of their community
or gravitate to you.
So it's a win-win.
So with that, thanks for joining
and I believe tomorrow we're gonna have
Tom Friedman if I saw
the calendar correctly,
either tomorrow or in the near future.
So that's going to be a really
interesting conversation.
And hopefully by tomorrow I will have my,
actually, I think my
appointment is right after this
and my tooth will probably
be hurting even more.
But (laughs) look forward
to seeing all of y'all,
in tomorrow's live stream.